sensations fortes pour des futurs
astronautes pour les 50 ans des premiers
pas sur la lune
magny les hameaux lui dédie ses rtt
depuis dix ans la ville propose une
semaine d'activités face à l'estaminet
on a décidé de fêter un peu cet
événement c'est vrai qu'il y a une
cinquantaine d'années tout le monde
pensait que dans cinquante ans plus tard
on serait en vivre est tous sur la lune
c'est pas encore le cas donc bon ben
voilà on remet ça un petit peu au goût
du jour et puis ça change un peu des
traditionnelles fêtes que l'on fait
d'habitude
pour nous c'est essentiel de pouvoir
faire une petite jonction entre la fin
de l'école et puis on va dire le 14
juillet près 220 encadrants sont
présents sur le pas de tir création de
fusées structures gonflables des
trampolines les activités destinées aux
centres de loisirs et aux familles à
budget en particulier qui t'ont terrasse
oui la grande tour là-bas
et pourquoi pas ce que fait on on s'est
tu et grimper aussi c'est bien c'est
bien on va franchement si bien bon voilà
pour commencer les vacances
hier on a fait
le cerf-volant on a fait l'avion là il a
tout les jeux en bois ils adorent ça
apparemment cette semaine c'est bien ils
sont pas encore tous partis en vacances
apparaît ça permet de les occuper
remettez tong est prévu jusqu'au samedi
13 juillet un pique nique républicain
conclura ses rtt pour en profiter il ne
vous reste plus qu'à vous équiper